Ein wichtige Kipppunkt des Klimawandels ist
jetzt erreicht worden, rund 70 Jahre früher
als die Klimawissenschaft vorausgesagt hatte.
Und Kipppunkt bedeutet, dass hier ein Prozess
in Gang gekommen ist, der den Klimawandel
verstärkt und nicht mehr aufzuhalten ist.
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Herzlich willkommen!
Die deutsche Bundesregierung hat schwere Schuld
auf sich geladen.
Sie hat viel zu wenig gegen den Klimawandel
getan und das, obwohl sie über den Weltklimarat
umfassend über die dramatische Situation
informiert ist.
Es wird sich in Zukunft zeigen, ob sich die
zuständigen Politikerinnen und Politiker
nicht irgendwann vor Gericht verantworten
müssen.
Denn das ist tatsächlich Massenmord.
Und niemand kann sagen, sie oder er hätte
es nicht gewusst.
Jetzt ist eine der schlimmsten Katastrophen
eingetreten.
Die Permafrostböden, die normalerweise ganzjährig
gefroren sind, tauen.
Und das in einem Ausmaß, wie es für 2090
vorhergesagt worden war.
Dazu beigetragen haben solche Extremereignisse,
wie der heiße Sommer letztes Jahr, bei dem
zum ersten Mal, seitdem Menschen das Wetter
erfassen, die gesamte Nordhalbkugel warm war.
Die extreme Aufheizung der letzten Jahre hat
dazu geführt, dass der Permafrostboden mit
einer dramatischen Geschwindigkeit auftaut.
In einigen Gebieten Kanadas ist der Boden
inzwischen stark abgetaut.
Zwischen 2003 und 2016 ist der Boden zum Teil
fast einen Meter abgesackt.
So ein Forschungsteam um die britische Geologin
Louise Farquharson.
Und laut einer Langzeitstudie des Alfred-Wegener-Instituts
aus Bremerhaven ist die Bodentemperatur zwischen
2007 und 2016 im Mittel um 0,3 Grad Celsius
angestiegen.
Der Untergrund gibt somit nach und gefährdet
die Stabilität von Straßen und Gebäuden.
Zudem hat das Ganze explosive Folgen für
uns alle - und das im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Denn durch das Tauen der Permafrostböden
wird Gashydrat frei, das im Boden eingelagert
ist.
Das Gemisch ist gefroren und besteht aus Methan
und Wasser.
Wenn es erwärmt wird, explodiert es.
In Sibirien gab es bereits enorme Detonationen,
von denen riesige Krater zurückbleiben.
Aber auch das Erdklima muss darunter leiden,
denn das Tauen des Permafrostes setzt letztendlich
gigantische Mengen an Kohlendioxid und Methan
frei, die zu den langlebigen Treibhausgasen
zählen und zur Erderwärmung beitragen.
Konkret wird durch das Tauen der Böden eine
große Menge Biomasse aus abgestorbenen Pflanzen
frei, die dann durch Bodenbakterien zersetzt
wird.
Und bei diesem Prozess entsteht Methan und
Kohlendioxid - und das nicht zu knapp.
Nicht umsonst wird das Schmelzen des Permafrosts
in der Arktis als sogenannter Kipppunkt bezeichnet.
Und der ist jetzt erreicht.
Rückkopplungs-Effekte im globalen Klimasystem
also, die am Ende dafür sorgen, dass sich
die Erwärmung der Erde selbst verstärkt.
Es ist also kein Wunder, dass die Sommertemperaturen
im Schnitt so dramatisch steigen.
Der schmelzende Permafrostboden beschleunigt
diesen Prozess noch einmal.
Aber wir alle können ganz konkret etwas tun.
Alte Autos mit Verbrennungsmotoren verschrotten
lassen.
(Und funktionierende CO2-Schleudern schnell
loswerden.
Noch gibt es Geld dafür.
Das wird sich aber in den nächsten paar Jahren
dramatisch ändern.)
Stromanbieter wählen, die ausschließlich
Strom aus regenerativen Energien anbieten.
Weniger Fliegen!
Und alles was man an CO2 verbraucht mit Klimazertifikaten
ausgleichen.
Für mich sind das im Monat 13 Euro, die ich
zahle.
Das kann man doch verknusen.
Und geht euren Bundestagsabgeordneten auf
die Nerven und fragt sie, was dafür tun,
damit Deutschland die Klimaziele für 2020
doch noch einhalten kann.
Es ist zu spät!
Jetzt geht es darum, das Schlimmste zu verhindern!
Sollen wir einen eigenen Kanal zum Thema Umwelt
und Natur machen?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare!
Und falls ihr jemand kennt, der immer noch
zweifelt.
Dem empfehle ich das Video: Klimawandel bestätigt!
Skeptiker endgültig widerlegt!
Anklicken, anschauen und natürlich Clixoom
Science & Fiction abonnieren.